足の爪きりたいこんにちははず社長です共有とばを3や
今日0卵3ってやつがあるんですけどもう可能をやるって水中から出現ということで
ですね
なぜこう水の中に個の卵が入ってるんですけどこの卵を入れておくと48時間から72
時間ぐらい店めちゃくちゃ大きい恐竜になるという
こういう卵がね日本の市場ではこういうやー
こういうのがちょっと出てるんですよ要するに水に入れると今度
な卵が大きくなって思いな距離が羽化する
こういうおもちゃ買う理由があってはサガンが入っている
な人とりあえずこれをですねこの卵を水のコップとかに入れておくと48時間または
72時間ほど小松と巨大化して大きな恐竜が孵化するっていう
そこで俺は考えたコーンお店にある分だけちょっと全部買ってきたんですよ
する地域234個ほどあるんですけども今回こちらの距離ん太郎を全部
一気に負荷で6そうにしてたが入らないと思うんで今日はそう予想の中
恐竜でいっぱいにしてプロの中でざらしっくパークを作ってると思う
48スリムから72時間活動すべてのて僕が浮かすそうすることによりトレンド
クローンだからそのよそうなば全部距離だぎーなって者らしってパイプになると僕は
思うんですよお風呂で打ち込んでいこうとます
気づいたら
2週間が経っていましたじゃじゃーんなんか急にめんどくさくなって野球もなくなっ
ちゃって
気づいたら磁石当たってていつもシャワーしか見ないして語表現の卵ですね金谷城入れ
たんですけども
まず48時間でタマゴ孵化さらに72時間子はいつかをかけると恐竜の max の
大きさになる
どこをが中4日間漬けたんでおやもうさぞかし大きくなっていることだと思いますよ
早速が見てみましょう
はこんな
感じですねプルーンぷるーん
あースっぽくハゲちゃってるんですよね
2週間がいたらそれふやけるはこいつに出さまあ勝率ってちゃんもう
取れちゃうねみんな気がしちゃってる二週間はさすがにきついかお前ら
トリケラトプスわー失敗こちらの saas 別に足が折れます
me
ああああああ
いいえ meg
ええええええ
ています